the first thing is whenever you see one
of these alpha beta questions pretty
much out of instinct even if they don't
tell you - in this question you should
work out what the sum and the product
are just just do that because you're
gonna need to use those building blocks
in this case alpha plus beta will be
minus B on a so should negative four and
this one will be CLA which is just 2
so there are my building blocks so then
my question is okay well how do I build
this thing out of these now it's not
necessarily a bad thing that you're
going to have to do some expansion
because especially when you see cubes
are a bit of a culprit they are often I
keep doing that
they are often quite hard to work with
so let's let's just give this a go and
see what happens so the left-hand side
of this thing is one on alpha cubed plus
one on beta cubed so when I think about
how these things are gonna go together I
think when I see a pair of fractions by
instinct is to get common denominators
and could buy them into one fraction so
let's go ahead and do that if I multiply
this by beta cubed or beta cubed I'll
get this right that's that one and then
if I multiply this by alpha cubed on
alpha cubed
I'll get this on the same denominator
that okay now before I move any further
this thing down the bottom I I can work
out directly because something cubes
have something cubed is this or cubed do
you agree so I can use that I all
rewrite the bottom like so now this is
just me mentally filing away okay I know
what to do with that all good okay but
then you come to the top and you're like
oh we're gonna do with this now I as a
two units do in fact you know an
identity they can help you with this
numerator it's the summer of two things
that have been cubed so what's the sum
of cubes cubes identity do you know it
yep very good very good fantastic and
you've got this on your reference sheet
which is nice so you've got this yep
it's on the reference tree okay so
that's
Wow okay now this is really good because
I know what alpha plus beta is I know
what alpha beta is there's another
alphabet here and so that all it's left
is is what I do with these guys okay now
so what I'm doing is I'm trying to see
through the question notice these guys
are the issue now so I'm going to focus
on those okay now this this bit takes a
bit of fiddling okay to get an alpha
squared and a beta squared can you see
that squaring this guy is not good
enough because the alpha squared of the
beta squared will then be tangled up
together you'll get alpha squared times
b2 squared and you can't separate them
so therefore I'm going to have to do
something with this guy because they
have the Alpha and the beta separately
yes so if I squared this on the left
hand side if I expand it all out what
would I get
yeah alpha beta plus B squared you agree
and that's 16 okay
now I actually don't quite have that but
I've got something very close to that
watch this hey I'm gonna subtract
something so I'm gonna do it two things
in this next line the first thing is I'm
going to replace these guys I don't need
to keep writing them I know what they
are numerically so that's negative 4 on
the denominator I have 2 cubed is that
okay now what do I have in here well I'm
gonna write this in terms of this so
it's alpha squared plus 2 alpha beta
plus b2 squared I've done this because I
know what that's equal to but this of
course is not equal to what I wrote in
the last line to compensate I need to
subtract 3 alpha beta is that okay sure
enough this that's equal to that I'm
good I'm pretty much there so this is
negative 4 times because I've written it
over there I can just substitute it for
16 so if you write this down so you can
refer to it you're good
minus 3 times what's that - and then
you're pretty much home
host okay it is important that in order
to do in order to simply write down 16
here I have to have written somewhere
that alpha square plus 2 out beta plus
beta squared is you go to 16 just like I
have here if I hadn't have written this
down I've got a show
probably my intervening line would be
this I need to show I recognize what
that is because remember you know what
this answer is going to be so therefore
just getting the number is not good
enough you actually have to show the
steps the logic the logic that gets you
there okay